est-ce que la fantaisie c'est de droite
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de sociologique ça commence à
faire un petit moment que j'ai pas fait
un bon vieil épisode pop culture et bien
aujourd'hui on part pour une petite
virée dans les contrées médiévales et
fantastiques à la recherche du sens
politique de la fantaisie pourquoi il
faudrait forcément politiser la
fantaisie ça pourrait pas rester juste
en divertissement et bien sache stupide
joue flux qu'une œuvre est toujours
politique ne serait-ce que par son
message ou la représentation du monde
qu'elle propose et pour s'en convaincre
il n'y a qu'à voir les réactions qu'on
susciter les simples affiches de la
série les anneaux de pouvoir qu'on a
accusé de walkisme simplement pour avoir
casté des acteurs noirs des réactions
comme ça venant de soi-disant fans de
fantaisie moi ça me fait me poser
quelques questions non mais tu peux pas
partir de la réaction de quelques trolls
de Twitter pour porter un jugement sur
toute la fantaisie alors oui évidemment
pas toute la fantaisie il y en a des
dizaines de sous genres qui peuvent
représenter des mondes et des messages
parfois très éloignés par exemple si on
regarde ce que propose l'algorithme de
classement cette gauche ou de droite je
vois que si je tape le Seigneur des
Anneaux on me dit que à droite alors que
si je propose les royaumes du nord la
saga de Philippe Pullman on me dit que
c'est de gauche alors je t'arrête tout
de suite je sais très bien que c'est pas
un classement objectif et que les gens
votent pour influencer les résultats
mais justement ça nous donne un indice
de l'appropriation de ces œuvres par les
internautes et si je regarde ces
classements sous forme d'un graphique
plus nuancé et ben on voit que Tolkien
c'est plutôt de droite bon toujours à
gauche de Macron faut pas déconner non
plus alors que dans le même temps Harry
Potter et Star Wars sont plutôt de
gauche au même niveau que le café ou la
raclette ok du coup si je comprends bien
sur ton schéma là Tintin et Batman ça
commence à être sérieusement de droite
au même niveau que de Gaulle Booba ou se
laver c'est pas moi qui fait les règles
bref tout ça pour dire que il y a de la
diversité dans la fiction mais ici je
vais m'intéresser à la fantasy
médiévalisante à l'image du Seigneur des
anneaux ou de Game of Thrones où on est
projeté dans un univers qui présente de
nombreuses similitudes avec notre
Moyen-Âge de fait dans ces histoires en
suit souvent les récits de roi de reine
de chevaliers bref de nobles et
d'aristocrates qui remplissent un destin
extraordinaire
et justement je sais bien que vous aimez
tous Aragorn il est mince il est beau il
sent bon le sable chaud il pète la
classe quand il desse des nazegules et
les shootent dans les têtes d'orques
comme personne
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous savez que
dans cette scène et bien oui on sait
ok bon reprenons du coup certes Aragorn
il est bon à poutrer de l'orque mais
est-ce que ça en fait pour autant un bon
roi est-ce qu'on aurait voté pour lui si
on était dans un régime démocratique
pas besoin
non mais là c'est clairement Ned star
qui fait son rageux parce que dans les
bouquins Tolkien il dit clairement que
oui ça va être un bon roi d'abord il a
été choisi par son peuple parce que
c'est le roi de la prophétie qu'elle est
ma guérisseuse puis en plus il dit noir
sur blanc qui va régner avec justesse
pendant 122 ans mais justement
l'histoire est construite pour que ça se
passe comme ça elle est faite de telle
façon qu'on soit du côté du roi perdu
qui retrouve son trône après des
centaines d'années de régence mais
justement c'est précisément cet angle là
qu'il faut interroger parce que
imaginons qu'on transpose ça dans la
vraie vie bon bah nous aussi on l'a
notre Aragorn déchu regarde il s'appelle
Louis Bourbon de façon très originale
c'est l'actuel duc d'Anjou et l'héritier
légitimiste au trône de France bon
actuellement il vit en Espagne parce que
depuis la mort sans enfant du comte de
Chambord en 1883 c'est la branche
espagnole des Bourbon qui est devenu
l'héritière du trône ceux qui en fait le
descendant de Louis XIV par son père et
l’arrière petit-fils de Franco par sa
mère un super combo mais bref depuis
1889 il revendique officiellement le
trône de France sous le nom de Louis XX
et je suis sûr qu'avec un peu de talent
littéraire on pourrait carrément en
faire une grande fresque romantique où
le roi qu'on croyait perdu revient
prendre sa juste place pour gouverner
son peuple regarde on a même de belles
images où on le voit en train de
soutenir les gilets jaunes c'est pas
beau ça je pense que les Français
peut-être ont été un peu abandonnés bon
évidemment je grossis le trait mais
c'est juste pour souligner que à la base
être du côté du roi qui prend le pouvoir
c'est pas trop la gauche quoi en général
on a plutôt deux traditions avec les
rois ça c'est culturel hein c'est sûr
que dit comme ça
mais du coup Aragorn est un gros réac et
ben justement c'est pas aussi simple bah
oui sinon j'aurais juste dit oui la
fantaisie c'est de droite et il y aurait
pas d'épisode on va voir que c'est pas
parce qu'une histoire se passe au
Moyen-âge et qu'on a des rois tout le
tour du ventre que le contenu est
nécessairement réactionnaire mais pour
bien comprendre ça il va falloir revenir
un peu en arrière pour réfléchir aux
origines de la fantaisie on est parti
[Musique]
la fantaisie est en genre littéraire qui
met en scène des mondes imaginaires la
spécialiste Anne Besson dans son
Dictionnaire de la fantaisie définit le
genre comme l'ensemble des œuvres dont
le monde fictionnel qu'il s'agisse d'une
autre ou d'un monde secondaire autonome
qu'il communique ou prennent place dans
un multivers et marquée par la présence
du surnaturel magique bon du coup il
semble que pour avoir affaire de la
fantaisie on a besoin de seulement deux
ingrédients d'abord l'existence d'une
forme de magie ou de surnaturel et
ensuite le fait que tout ça prenne place
dans un monde à part et cohérent ou ce
surnaturel et la norme c'est une
définition assez large et en réalité il
existe une tétrachiée de sous genre qui
ont chacun la spécificité tu peux nous
donner quelques exemples mais tout à
fait on a tout d'abord l'héroïque
fantasy où on bon français le sort des
sources où l'on suit un héros solitaire
comme dans Conan le Barbare on a la High
fantasy epic on est projeté dans un
monde entièrement magique et nouveau
choisi et l'artiste anglais William
Morris qui est sans doute plus connu
aujourd'hui pour ses motifs décoratifs
que pour avoir inventé un genre
littéraire nouveau William Morris est un
socialiste révolutionnaire engagé et
cela se ressent dans ses écrits son
livre le plus connu nouvelle de nulle
part décrit un futur
utopique socialiste en l'an 2102 dans
lequel les individus ont rejeté la ville
et l'industrie pour revenir à la
campagne à l'artisanat pour Maurice le
moyen-âge est par extension la fantaisie
la magie et l'enfance préfigurent un
monde post capitaliste qui verra un
quasi-retour à l'état originel
rousseauiste ah oui et puis là on voyait
qu'il était carrément cofondateur de la
Ligue socialiste en Angleterre donc le
mec fait vraiment pas semblant tout à
fait et c'est le socialisme du 19e
siècle on sait pas le même sens
qu'aujourd'hui William Morris est
beaucoup moins connu en France notamment
parce qu'il a été traduit très
tardivement le fait il a fallu attendre
2017 pour pouvoir découvrir en français
la source au bout du monde de la pleine
étincelante mais il aura tout de même un
impact assez considérable notamment
auprès des auteurs Tolkien et CS Lewis
qui feront explicitement référence à
William Morris comme une source
d'inspiration en somme c'est un peu
l'auteur de fantasy préféré de ton
auteurs de fantaisie préféré un peu oui
mais n'allons pas trop vite en besogne
après William Morris la fantaisie va
connaître plusieurs renaissances d'abord
aux États-Unis dans les années 30 à
travers les récits pulp qui paraissent
dans les tails c'est là que va
apparaître notamment Conan le Barbare de
Robert eoward mais celui qui va
durablement marquer l'avènement de la
fantasy c'est bien évidemment le
philologue et médiéviste John Ronald
Rewell Tolkien avec le Hobbit en 1937
puis la saga du Seigneur des Anneaux en
1955 oui c'est une petite trilogie de
bouquins qui a un peu marché à l'époque
pas très connu et ça y est si vous avez
l'occasion
il y a pas à dire quand on parle de
fantaisie Tolkien c'est le gangster
original il a profondément redéfini le
genre et c'est sur lui que vont
s'appuyer tous les écrivains qui vont
lui succéder mais sur le plan politique
on est bien loin des velléités
socialistes dans William Morris il
reprend bien sûr certains thèmes comme
une réflexion sur la modernité mais il
refuse de faire de son récit une oeuvre
politique pour lui la quête de Frodo est
avant tout humaine par ailleurs il est
lui-même plutôt conservateur et ses
histoires sont empreintes d'un certain
catholicisme même si cela reste quand
même assez subtil et qu'on ne tombe pas
non plus dans la représentation directe
du Dieu unique comme ça peut être le cas
dans le monde de Narnia de son ami SS
Lewis oui je crois qu'on peut dire que
c'est un peu Jean-Michel subtilité dans
la fantasy mais revenons au coeur du
sujet parce que je vous rappelle qu'à la
base ici on est sur une chaîne de
sociologie et il se trouve que justement
les thèmes et les réflexions qu'on voit
dans les tous premiers écrits de fantasy
et Ben sont précisément ceux qui ont
amenés à la naissance de la sociologie
autrement dit Durkheim Tolkien même
combat alors là je suis obligé de
t'arrêter parce que tu te souviens la
dernière fois quand tu m'as forcé à lire
les règles de la méthode sociologique
parce que j'avais confondu un problème
social et un problème sociologique bon
bah j'ai pas trouvé ça méga fun il y a
pas beaucoup d'elfes et de Hobbit si tu
vois ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
bon après j'imagine que ça reste
toujours plus facile à lire que le
Silmarillon mais quand même ne
t'inquiète pas je vais tout expliquer
[Musique]
à la base la sociologie n'est à la fin
du 19e siècle d'une réflexion sur la
modernité il faut bien voir que le 19e
c'est un siècle de profonde
transformation à la fois politique
économique et sociale ah oui j'ai le
vélo quoi bah le vélo ça a été inventé
au début du 19e d'ailleurs tu as
remarqué qu'on voit jamais de vélo dans
les histoires de fantasy non parce que
pour aller à cheval il y a du monde mais
à part ça c'est tout à pied alors que
franchement une paire de VTT Frodo et ça
ils arrivaient au Mordor en deux
pas si facilement en Mordor oui après le
vélo ça fait pas trop fantaisie
justement parce que c'est trop attaché à
la modernité et ça ferait bizarre dans
un environnement médiéval après tu sais
quand je parlais de grandes
transformations je pensais plutôt à la
révolution industrielle tu sais là la
machine à vapeur le train l'électricité
tout ça cette transformation a marche
forcée fait basculer des sociétés à
dominantes agraires et artisanales vers
des sociétés commerciales et
industrielles avec l'accélération de
l'exode rural et le développement des
grandes usines qui s'accompagnent de la
généralisation du travail ouvrier et
paupérisé en particulier on assiste à
l'abandon des petites communautés
agraires et traditionnelles pour une vie
d'anonymes dans les grandes villes
marquées par les inégalités où l'on ne
connaît même plus son voisin de palier
de nombreux sociologues de cette période
comme Durkheim au Weber voit dans cette
urbanisation une transformation du lien
social et surtout une montée de
l'individualisme Weber étudie par
exemple la rationalisation de notre
rapport au monde notamment grâce aux
progrès de la science et il parle d'un
désenchantement du monde pour souligner
le véhicule des explications magiques et
religieuses au profit d'explications
scientifiques qui se veulent plus
rationnel mais aussi plus froides et
moins porteuse de sens pour les
individus Durkheim étudie lui aussi à sa
façon la perte de sens qui accompagne la
modernité et il voit dans l'augmentation
du nombre de suicides un signe de
l'éclatement des structures
traditionnelles de sociabilité
bah dis donc ça a l'air vachement joyeux
la modernité mais dis-toi bien que la
sociologie émerge précisément pour
essayer d'analyser et de contrer ce
qu'on appelle les pathologies sociales
comme la pauvreté le suicide
l'alcoolisme ou la violence qui pullule
au centre des grandes villes celui qui
étudie le plus clairement le changement
de paradigme dans les sociétés modernes
c'est le sociologue allemand-ferdinand
Tony dans son livre de 1887 communauté
et sociétés il énonce que lorsqu'on est
passé des sociétés traditionnelles aux
sociétés modernes le lien social s'est
transformé et qu'on est passé d'un lien
communautaire un lien chaud fondé sur la
cohésion la ressemblance et la coutume à
des liens sociétaires autrement dit des
liens froids volontairement choisis et
fondé sur le raisonnement et le calcul
comme les relations marchandes par
exemple autrement dit on serait passé
dans le monde où domine la famille le
village et la tradition vers un monde où
domine les relations marchandes
l'entreprise et la méfiance si cette
description vous rappelle quelque chose
et bien c'est fait exprès attends je
pense que je vais trouver le seigneur
des amis c'était le Seigneur des Anneaux
on va dire en même temps et oui l'oeuvre
de Tolkien peut complètement se lire
comme une métaphore du passage de la
communauté à la société qui aurait pu
prédire et oui les Hobbits sont
l'exemple même du lien communautaire ils
vivent dans de petits villages
s'intéressent peu au monde extérieur et
ils ont de nombreuses coutumes et
rivalités familiales qui les occupent
bien assez et le récit n’hésite jamais à
décrire par le menu tous les us et
coutumes des hobbits comme en témoigne
des 42 pages du prologue sur les
différentes variétés d'herbe à pipe mais
c'est qu'il nous tient à cœur c'est la
paix la tranquillité et une terre bien
cultivée car les Hobbits partagent
l'amour des choses qui poussent
nous décrit en fait ici un mode de vie
simple auquel il aspire à l'image de
l'Angleterre rurale et insouciante qu'il
a connu enfant et qui est en train de
disparaître parce que si le comté fait
figure d'un havre de paix encore
préservé le Seigneur des Anneaux se
passe à une époque bien plus sombre où
le Mordor industrieux menace de faire
surface et où la méfiance règne c'est
d'ailleurs parce qu'il essaye les
formules trop complexes que Gandalf ne
trouve pas le mot de passe de la Moria
là où le simple mot ami suffit en fait à
ouvrir les portes la formule d'ouverture
se trouvait un script sur l'arche depuis
le début il aurait fallu traduire dites
ami et entrez rien de plus simple trop
simple pour un maître tradition en ces
jours de défiance c'était une époque
plus heureuse d'ailleurs dans le
Seigneur des Anneaux tout ce qui renvoie
à l'industrie et clairement du côté du
mal on peut par exemple s'étonner que la
principale menace que fait peser un
Saroumane ne soit pas tant d'ordre
magique ce qui semblerait logique de la
part d'un magicien que d'ordre
industriel
il rase des forêts construit des armes
et fait des croisements génétiques pour
se constituer une armée d'or que
génétiquement modifiée
présent il a un esprit de métal et de
rouage
et ne se soucie plus des choses qui
poussent
mais outre cette opposition à la
technologie le Seigneur des Anneaux
marque aussi par son caractère
profondément mélancolique c'est assez
incontournable quand on lit les bouquins
Tolkien associe la modernité à une perte
perte de tradition perte de sens et en
particulier perte d'un lien fort entre
l'humanité et la nature on est bien dans
un monde magique mais cette magie est
justement en train de mourir l'histoire
se déroule précisément à la fin du
troisième âge au moment où les derniers
elfes quittent la Terre du Milieu qui
s'ouvre à leur pleinement sur l'âge des
hommes les hommes
ils sont faibles on croirait voir Weber
nous expliquer qu'avec la sédarisation
le 20e siècle s'ouvre sur un monde où la
rationalité froide a pris le pas sur la
magie et où l'on abandonne des
traditions et des croyances qui même si
elles étaient fausses permettaient de
créer du lien social
ce futur est presque révolu mais il
n'est pas perdue waouh tu sais quoi tu
me donnes presque envie de lire économie
et société
presque tout ça pour dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
quand on regarde une histoire qui se
passe à une époque médiévale la
fantaisie de dolkien nous parle en fait
de notre époque et elle entame une
réflexion sur la modernité pour Tolkien
c'est en particulier l'horreur de la
Grande Guerre qui sera l'étincelle de
son récit car c'est après avoir été
traumatisé par la bataille de la Somme
qu'il écrira la chute de Gondolin son
premier texte se déroulant en Terre du
Milieu et qui est clairement une
métaphore de la guerre industrielle
juste en remplaçant les chars par des
dragons mais c'est un thème qu'on va
retrouver dans beaucoup d'oeuvres de
fantasy à travers le monde si on regarde
ce qui sort en France à peu près au même
moment on peut voir la création
d'Astérix par Uderzo et Goscinny en 1959
comme relevant exactement la même
logique à leur façon les irréductibles
Gaulois répondent également aux
angoisses de l'urbanisation et de
l'industrialisation en mettant en scène
une petite communauté villageoise et
soudée qui vit dans une forêt en
conservant des traditions et un lien
magique avec la nature et surtout qui
tentent de survivre au monde globalisant
représenté par l'empire romain
[Musique]
là
ah mais attends c'est ouf j'avais jamais
vu Astérix et Obélix comme de la fantasy
mais il y a tous les ingrédients en fait
oh on vit vraiment dans une saucisse et
oui bon faisons un petit point d'étape
les récits fantaisie se déroulent
souvent dans des univers médiévaux qui
mettent en scène des rois des reines et
des chevaliers souvent glorifiés mais
parallèlement ils sont au contraire des
allégories de la modernité et ils
mettent en garde le lecteur contre les
dangers de l'air industriel et c'est
tout le problème quand on veut avoir le
fin mot d'un récit mythique ou
allégorique c'est que on peut
l'interpréter de différentes façons et
c'est particulièrement vrai avec les
récits de Tolkien qui vont être repris
aussi bien par la gauche que par la
droite à gauche c'est notamment dans les
années 60 et 70 que la jeunesse
contestataire découvre Tolkien à la
faveur de l'édition de poche et qui en
fait une lecture écologiste et
anticapitaliste et il aura d'ailleurs de
nombreux épisodes en ce sens on peut
citer par exemple le cycle de Shannara
commencé en 1977 par l'auteur Terry
Brooks et qui est une sorte de décalque
conforme de Tolkien associe près qu'au
lieu de se placer directement au
Moyen-Âge l'action se déroule désormais
après une apocalypse nucléaire qui a
provoqué le retour des races anciennes
comme les Elfes les nains ou les gnomes
ici c'est donc le refus du productivisme
et du consumérisme alimenté par une
crainte eschatologique qu'on connaît
plutôt bien aujourd'hui qui fait place
au retour cyclique à une époque
médiévaliste mais fatalement certains
ont aussi fait une lecture réactionnaire
de ses retours à une situation
antérieure vu comme idéalisée la
dernière réappropriation en date et sans
doute celle de la politicienne italienne
néo fasciste Giorgia mélony qui est déjà
revenu plusieurs fois sur son amour du
Seigneur des Anneaux à la fois dans son
autobiographie et en interview elle
affirme se retrouver dans les Hobbits ou
les humains lorsqu'il combattent toutes
sortes de créatures maléfiques et elle y
voit une métaphore du combat du peuple
italien face à l'Union européenne le
multiculturalisme ou la mondialisation
[Musique]
là tolken il a toujours eu un discours
d'ouverture et de tolérance et surtout
il sait toujours opposé à toute forme de
totalitarisme ça on le voit très
clairement dans les lettres qu'il a
envoyé mais même dans son il suffit de
lire le seigneur de nos une fois pour
s'en persuader oui mais justement elle
voit bien ce qu'elle veut y voir bon je
précise quand même que pour le grand
spécialiste de Tolkien Vincent Ferret la
lecture que fait Meloni du Seigneur des
Anneaux est complètement à côté de la
plaque mais c'est assez choquant parce
que tout ce qui est dit va à l'encontre
à la fois des convictions de géant
Tolkien comme personne et des messages
du livre Le Seigneur des Anneaux aussi
pluriel que soit ce message mais ça nous
montre quand même que plusieurs
interprétations sont possibles du coup
il va falloir observer d'un peu plus
près le message politique des oeuvres de
fantaisie pour se faire un avis plus
informé et pour ça on va regarder en
particulier comment est représenter le
pouvoir médiéval
[Musique]
pour commencer si Tolkien choisit un
environnement médiéval pour faire se
dérouler son histoire je pense qu'il
faut pas vraiment y chercher un sens
politique à mon avis la réponse est
beaucoup plus à chercher du côté de ces
centres d'intérêt il est lui-même
médiéviste philologue donc spécialiste
des langues anciennes et il a lu tous
les de chevalerie qui sont sa première
source d'inspiration donc il est un
écrivain il a un engouement pour
certaines thématiques et puis ils
récupèrent des éléments pour
reconstruire son monde fantastique
l'idée l'idéologie elle vient après elle
vient de ceux qui tout d'abord présente
ou interprète et peut-être aussi par
ceux qui regardent mais justement il
faut bien faire la différence entre
l'inspiration et la réalité le Seigneur
des Anneaux c'est pas un cours
d'histoire médiévale et lorsque Tolkien
utilise le moyen-âge je pense qu'il faut
davantage y voir un terreau fertile
d'imaginaire et d'inspiration qu'une
volonté de décrire un système politique
c'est d'ailleurs précisément l'un des
reproches que lui fera plus tard Martins
l'auteur des livres Game of Thrones
il nous dit donc j'ai toujours autant
envie de discuter avec le professeur
Tolkien de différents aspects du livre
il a fait ce qu'il a fait brillamment
mais à la fin il dit karagorn est le roi
et qu'il va très bien gouverner pendant
100 ans c'est facile d'écrire cette
phrase mais j'aimerais savoir quelle est
sa politique en matière de taxe et
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait quand il y avait
de la famille et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
de tous les orques beaucoup d'or qu'on
survécu ils se sont enfus dans les
montagnes Aragorn a-t-il demandé un
génocide massif des orques a-t-il envoyé
ses chevaliers pour les tuer et les
bébés orques a-t-il essayé d'apprendre
aux Orres à être de bons citoyens et si
les orques sont issus des elfes
peuvent-ils se marier avec les elfes des
questions légitimes en effet mais qu'on
ne peut pas vraiment reprocher à Tolkien
de ne pas avoir traité parce que son
propos est bien différent de celui de
Martine Gire heureux veut faire une
fresque épique et mythologique qui
brasse les grands enjeux de bien et de
mal alors que géreux lui veut avant tout
faire une fresque politique qui laisse
la part belle aux intrigues
machiaveliennes et aux jeux de pouvoir
de fait le trône de fer se rattache
plutôt au sous-genre de la Grimm dark
fantasy typique de la fin du 20e siècle
on y voit peu de magie une violence
accrue et en profond développement
psychologique des personnages avec un
cadre médiéval présenté comme le plus
réaliste possible ouais alors réaliste
il faut le dire vite quand même parce
que j'ai pas souvenir qu'on est ravagé
des villes à d'autres dragons dans les
livres d'histoire alors évidemment on
reste dans de la fantaisie c'est pas non
plus un livre d'histoire mais il est de
notoriété publique que Martine s'est
inspiré de l'histoire médiévale et on
peut faire de nombreux parallèles entre
son œuvre et les réalités historiques
mais je vous renvoie vers des vidéos qui
parlent spécifiquement de ça pour plus
de détails ah ouais le mec externaliste
de travail pour pas avoir à me répondre
c'est un peu facile en fait le rapport
entre Martine c'est le moyen-âge est
assez complexe et il n'entrase pas non
plus un portrait fidèle s'il est
certainement plus proche de la réalité
médiévale que ce que pouvait faire
Tolkien il forcit quand même le trait et
il porte en regard très sombre sur cette
société sa politique et de façon
générale sur la nature humaine et pour
le coup je vous renvoie au livre une
histoire de feu et de sang le moyen-âge
dans Game of Thrones écrit par les
historiens médiésiste Florian Besson et
juste une breton si vous voulez en
savoir plus
mais ce qui est tout de même intéressant
chez Martine c'est qu'il nous donne une
représentation assez juste du pouvoir
médiéval notamment dans sa dimension
brutale et violente et comme le souligne
justement Florian Besson les chevaliers
les seigneurs les rois et les empereurs
médiévaux n'hésitent pas à utiliser
cette violence punition exemplaire
châtiment corporel violence arbitraire
font partie de l'arsenal classique du
pouvoir et du coup par contraste cette
violence du pouvoir politique dans
l'oeuvre de Martine elle fait d'autant
plus ressortir le fait qu'elle soit
quasiment absente dans les autres œuvres
de fantasy médiévales ouais enfin il me
semble qu'on voit quand même Saroumane
cramer un peu des villages non oui mais
justement c'est un méchant on ne verrait
jamais ça de la part dans gentil ou
alors vraiment seulement pendant la
guerre et du coup c'est une violence qui
est dirigée vers encore extérieur en
gros pas de problème pour voir Aragorn
dézinguer de l'orque par charrette de 50
mais on ne présentera jamais comme un
seigneur dominant son propre peuple on
n'imagine pas par exemple violer une
femme croisée dans les couloirs de Mina
Styrie tout brûlé et Doras pour punir
les rotérimes de leur insubordination ou
pendre des paysans qui viendraient se
plaindre des impôts effectivement c'est
pas trop le personnage pourtant ce sont
des pratiques absolument normales pour
un seigneur au Moyen-Âge mais qui ferait
clairement basculer notre personnage
dans le camp des méchants dit comme ça
le camp des méchants ça fait un peu
manichéen non ah oui totalement mais la
fantaisie est un genre plutôt manichéen
si on fait l'exception du courant un peu
green dark on a souvent un ennemi
clairement identifié et qui représente
l'opposé totale de nos héros il est
souvent noir maléfique dominateur et
violent et ce traitement soulève
clairement la question du rapport au
pouvoir politique qu'entretiennent les
héros de fantasy parce qu'en fait les
auteurs de fantasy essayent de tenir
ensemble ce qui devrait normalement être
une contradiction nous présenter des
personnages de gentil mais qui occupent
une place dont l'exercice ordinaire les
placerait normalement dans la catégorie
de méchants selon nos échelles de valeur
contemporaines et du coup pour essayer
de faire tenir ces deux bouts ensemble
on va souvent rencontrer des personnages
qui refusent le pouvoir c'est ce qu'on
va voir maintenant petite parenthèse je
précise que pour tout ce passage je
m’appuie en particulier sur un article
de Florian Besson qui s'intitule arrêté
de m'appeler Cyr les enjeux du refus du
pouvoir à travers la fantaisie
médiévaliste le lien sera bien sûr dans
la description
[Musique]
et oui une quasi constante des récits de
fantaisie c'est que les gentils refusent
généralement le pouvoir dans le Seigneur
des Anneaux pas moins de trois
personnages vont refuser le pouvoir de
l'anneau pourtant présenter comme
absolument corrupteur il me fou les poil
à chaque fois ce passage et ce qui est
remarquable c'est que tous ces
personnages semblent avoir réellement
peur du pouvoir
il pourrait atteindre à pouvoir trop
grand et trop terrible à imaginer et
d'une façon générale la fantaisie est
pleine de personnages qui refusent la
responsabilité d'un pouvoir dont il ne
se jugerait pas digne dans les
chroniques de Condor par exemple Pug
renonce à son titre de tout puissant
pour redevenir simplement Pug dans la
série animée Avatar le dernier maître de
l'air en graisse enfermé dans la glace
pendant 100 ans précisément parce qu'il
fuit ses responsabilités d'Avatar de son
côté Harry Potter brise la Baguette de
Sureau à la fin du septième tome parce
que personne ne devrait avoir un tel
pouvoir et même dans la série Kaamelott
le roi Arthur Abdi en quelque sorte en
ne retirant pas l'épée du rocher et il
ne cessera par la suite de répéter son
refus du titre royal
c'est plus moi
roi
je suis plus roi c'est tout foutez-moi
la paix je ne suis plus roi pour la 30e
fois je n'ai plus rien à voir avec
Kaamelott arrêtez de m'appeler
de m'appeler
en même temps tu penses que c'est une
bonne situation ça roi de Bretagne en
fait ce schéma est tellement ancré dans
notre façon de lire la fantaisie qu'on
est immédiatement amené à penser que
quelqu'un qui reçoit le pouvoir le vif
forcément comme un fardeau je me
souviens maître fait cette remarque en
regardant la première saison de House of
the Dragon lorsque le roi viserris
annonce publiquement qu'il nomme sa
fille
héritière du trône je m'aperçois que mes
années de consommation de fantaisie
m'ont aussitôt amené à penser qu'elle ne
voulait pas de ce pouvoir et que les
prochains épisodes se centreraient sur
un refus du pouvoir de la part de rahira
et en fait il m'a fallu un petit moment
pour comprendre que si elle fait la
gueule là dans les épisodes suivants
c'est pas parce qu'elle voit le pouvoir
comme une charge trop grande mais c'est
parce qu'avec la naissance de son petit
frère elle est persuadée que son père va
la déshériter en sa faveur ce garçon que
vous avez toujours rêvé d'avoir
comme
un en fait elle veut le pouvoir et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a frappé à quel
point cette volonté de la part d'un
personnage présenté plutôt positivement
était en fait quelque chose de rare dans
la fantaisie l'esprit de ta mère m'en
est témoin
il ne sera pas supplanté
parce que dans la fantaisie le pouvoir
fait caca et surtout le pouvoir
politique absolu menace toujours de
dériver en tyrannie ça c'est
particulièrement visible dans les
oeuvres qui mettent en scène des empires
à l'inverse des régimes royaux qui
peuvent porter des individus
exceptionnels qui mettent en avant
l'honneur la tradition les empires eux
sont presque toujours des forces
brutales qui veulent coloniser
uniformiser les individus et par là
abolir les traditions et les valeurs
romantiques on a bien sûr l'Empire
romain dans Astérix et Obélix où
l'empire galactique dans Star Wars qui
sont des forces maléfiques qui nous
présentent des armées de Gus
parfaitement identiques contre
lesquelles se battent au contraire des
rebelles haut en couleur chez qui règne
la diversité et la connexion avec la
nature si on veut rester dans la fantasy
médiévale l'exemple le plus parlant est
sans doute le cycle de l'Épée de Vérité
de Terry good kheim le héros Ray Charles
de s'oppose à l'ordre impérial un empire
maléfique dirigé par l’empereur jackang
qui contrôle tous ses soldats par la
pensée bon je vais pas vous cacher qu'on
est dans une espèce de caricature assez
grossière de l'URSS d'ailleurs le héros
de terrigo de Kai n'est sûrement la
figure la plus emblématique de ce refus
du pouvoir qui tombe vraiment comme une
malédiction parce que dans la première
partie du cycle avant d'affronter
l'ordre impérial il se bat en fait
contre le Seigneur du Mal darkenraed qui
se révélera après maintes péripéties
être en réalité son père attends attends
j'ai déjà vu ce schéma narratif quelque
part mais où et par conséquent à la mort
du méchant il hérite du pouvoir de son
père qu'il refuse car il le voit comme
une malédiction avilissante mais bon il
va quand même finir par accepter le
pouvoir ah bah ouf j'avais peur et au
grand étonnement de tout le monde il se
montrera un roi juste et bon il rendra
notamment sa liberté au peuple d'Aran en
tenant des grands discours sur la
liberté individuelle qui sembleront tout
droit sorti de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme non sérieux je sais pas si
vous avez déjà lu l'Épée de Vérité mais
dès que Richard commence à faire un
discours politique j'ai l'impression de
lire du Adam Smith mais le cadre Richard
est bien représentatif parce que on est
bien obligé de constater que dans la
fantaisie si les rois les élus et les
héritiers font dans un premier temps des
pudeurs de gazelle et il commence par
refuser le pouvoir qui leur ai le choix
bon bah en général ils finissent presque
toujours par CD et par accepter leur
charge du coup il faut qu'on regarde
comment se passe cette acceptation
finale du pouvoir
de fait même s'il passe leur temps à
cracher dessus les héros de fantaisie
finissent presque toujours par accepter
le pouvoir ils sont d'ailleurs
généralement des élus des héritiers ou
même des personnages carrément choisis
par les dieux qui se voit confier une
mission de service public et du coup ils
ont donc le pouvoir bien plus par devoir
de servir que par volonté de puissance
d'ailleurs les récits fantaisie sont
souvent des histoires au cours duquel le
voyage du héros permet aux personnages
principales d'assumer son rôle naturel
en le rendant légitime à gouverner et il
faut bien voir que c'est une question
qui ne viendrait absolument pas à
l'esprit d'un vrai roi médiéval pour lui
sa légitimité elle est inhérente à sa
naissance il y a pas de syndrome de
l'imposteur chez le molaire absolu alors
que dans la fantaisie c'est pas la même
tisane pourquoi
-vous en personne Aragorn par exemple a
peur de prendre le pouvoir parce qu'il
est hanté par la malédiction des îles
durs et il a peur de commettre les mêmes
erreurs que lui je ne veux pas de ce
pouvoir
n'est jamais voulu
vous êtes le dernier de cette lignée il
y en a aucune autre
attends mais d'où ils sortent ces
passages là je les ai jamais vu ça c'est
sûrement parce que tu regardes les
versions cinéma et pas les versions
longues il y a des versions longues
pourquoi je te parle en fait de fait la
version longue de Peter Jackson
développe bien plus le caractère torturé
d'Aragorn qui rumine la faiblesse des
idures et on vient à perdre la foi dans
toute l'humanité avez-vous si peu foi en
votre peuple
oui il y a de la faiblesse il y a de la
fragilité mais il y a aussi le courage
et le sens de l'honneur chez les hommes
mais vous ne le voyez pas c'est
notamment ce parcours d'Aragorn au cours
du film qui rend la mort de Boromir si
puissante émotionnellement
en lui parlant de notre peuple il lui
indique qu'il stoppe enfin ses
ruminations et qu'il est désormais prêt
à prendre la place qui lui incombe à
noter que sa dimension est quand même
bien plus présente dans les films parce
que dans les livres au moment où on le
rencontre il a déjà eu le temps de
rouler sa bosse avec les rôdeurs et il
est déjà prêt à jouer son rôle le moment
venu mais là encore pour le bien commun
[Musique]
dans la fantaisie le pouvoir n'est pas
un privilège dont on peut s'enorgueillir
mais au contraire c'est un fardeau dont
il faut se charger héroïquement et au
prix de grandes souffrances dans
Kaamelott le roi Arthur ira d'ailleurs
jusqu'à faire une tentative de suicide
et c'est bien la nécessité et
l'imploration par tous les autres qui
motivera son retour dans le film
qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous foutez là la seule
façon de rendre acceptable par nos
standards actuels un pouvoir absolu
semble donc de le donner explicitement à
un personnage qui n'en veut pas et dans
bien des récits c'est même précisément
le fait de refuser le pouvoir qui prouve
que le héros est légitime à l'exercer en
cela c'est tout à fait conforme à
l'éthique platonicienne du pouvoir qu'il
développe dans la République et c'est
presque exactement ce qu'explique
Dumbledore à Harry Potter dans le
dernier tome de la saga c'est une chose
curieuse à dire Harry mais peut-être que
les plus aptes à exercer le pouvoir
sont ceux qui ne l'ont jamais recherché
ce qui comme toi reçoivent la
responsabilité du commandement et Antho
se ce manteau parce qu'il le doivent
puis s'aperçoit valeurs grande surprise
qu'il le porte très bien et évidemment
une fois qu'ils ont fini par accepter le
pouvoir la légitimité de ses serviteurs
du peuple elle est encore renforcée par
le fait que généralement il passe des
lois justes et progressistes un peu
comme dans Kaamelott ou le roi Arthur a
aboli l'esclavage et il évite de cramer
ses paysans
comme une femme
bon ben je crois qu'on commence à y voir
plus clair et qu'on peut avoir une
vision un peu plus nuancée des récits de
fantaisie pour répondre à ma question
initiale non la fantaisie n'est pas
particulièrement de droite ce n'est pas
parce que les héros sont des rois et des
rennes médiévaux que le message
politique de la fantaisie serait une
glorification réactionnaire du pouvoir
monarchique et absolu bien au contraire
le pouvoir médiévalisant de la fantaisie
est une représentation bien éloignée des
violences réelles des régimes senioriaux
ce qui nous montre en filigrane ce que
nous trouvons acceptable ou non dans nos
sociétés contemporaines tous ces
puissants qui ne veulent pas l'être nous
disent au fond que nous voyons toujours
le pouvoir politique comme une
domination et justement ce refus du
pouvoir sert à nous rendre acceptable la
figure du héros autoritaire s'il est en
dominant légitime c'est parce que au
fond de lui il ne veut pas l'être le
fait est que nous sommes tellement
pétris idéal progressiste et
démocratique qu'il nous serait très
difficile d’être réellement du côté d'un
personnage véritablement dominateur et
assumant la violence du pouvoir à
travers cette fiction médiévalistes la
fantaisie nous dessine un monde idéal
dans lequel la domination serait
toujours supportable et légitime parce
que toujours exercé par des dominants
qui ne le seraient que malgré eux
Florian Besson termine ainsi son article
en précisant que c'est peut-être là que
réside toute la magie de la fantaisie en
fait pour refaire le parallèle avec la
société actuelle la fantaisie nous donne
à voir des rois et des reines légitimes
parce qu'ils acceptent de faire passer
le bien commun avant leur propre volonté
ce qui va en complète opposition avec
l'idéal individualiste de la société
actuelle au sein de laquelle les
structures monarchiques font un peu
désuète de fait encore aujourd'hui vivre
au sein de la monarchie c'est de voir
vivre selon un protocole et une
étiquette qui semblerait bien lourde à
beaucoup d'entre nous mais c'est
précisément cette tradition un peu
écrasante qui donne du pouvoir
symbolique à cette institution par
exemple lorsque Macron nous répète 42
fois que nous sommes en guerre au début
de la crise covid ça fait un peu
ridicule mais quand c'est la reine
Elizabeth qui s'adresse à la télévision
pour la quatrième fois seulement en 68
ans de règne et bah ça a tout de suite
un peu plus de poids et ça permet de
relativiser la situation
mais on peut aussi remarquer que ça fait
quelques années que les vieilles
monarchies semblent un peu en crise
évidemment on a la faire arriet Mégane
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre et
c'est vrai qu'on peut se moquer des
états d'âme du pauvre petit prince qui a
quand même beaucoup souffert et qui
pousse le mauvais goût jusqu'à filmer et
diffuser ses séances de psy
mais finalement ce n'est que le signe le
plus récent et éclatant d'un mouvement
de fond plus général que j'appellerais
la critique libérale de la monarchie où
cette dernière est décrié parce qu'elle
ne permet pas le libéralisme
émancipateur qu'on nous revend à toutes
les sauces dans le monde du travail
c'est dans ce contexte qu'on voit de
plus en plus d'héritiers de famille
royale se désolidariser de la monarchie
pour rechercher une émancipation
individuelle comme la princesse Martha
Louise de Norvège qui quitte la famille
royale en 2002 pour fonder une
entreprise de formation équestre ou le
prince Constantin des Pays-Bas qui
renonce en 2001 à son titre de prince
pour aller travailler dans un cabinet de
conseil il y aura encore plein
d'exemples mais comme on le voit on
quitte souvent la monarchie pour aller
faire carrière parce que aujourd'hui les
rentiers n'ont plus tellement bonne
presse et pour se réaliser il faut
travailler et si au passage c'est dans
un secteur qui paye bien c'est pas plus
mal non plus comme la très bien compris
notre bon roi Louis vain jeune banquier
affichant sa simplicité est-ce que vous
pourriez vivre sans travailler
malheureusement pas mais évidemment
qu'il est bon pied vous attendiez à quoi
finalement quand on nous vend partout la
singularisation et l'émancipation par le
travail une structure rigide comme une
famille royale qui proscrit souvent
l'activité économique mais ça peut être
vu comme une contrainte insupportable à
l'expression individuelle et à la
réalisation de soi mais mais quand même
je comprends je comprends carry il est
envie de s’assumer financièrement parce
que jusqu'à maintenant en tant que
membre de la famille royale je ne savais
pas mais ils ont pas le droit de
travailler ils ont pas le droit vous
rendez compte à quoi ça du ressembler
l'adolescence d'un riz Harry c'est la
dernière fois que je te le dis lâche
tout de suite ces offres d'emploi et
retournent ma TTC dans ta chambre
dans une boîte aux lettres et quand
j'aurai 18 ans je serai un stage et tu
pourras rien dire je te préviens rit si
tu ramènes un travail à la maison je te
renie eh ben tant mieux comme ça ce
serait le prince renier bref pour
résumer la société actuelle plus
libérale plus individualiste nous
enjoint à nous réaliser et à devenir
nous-mêmes et ainsi par corollaire on
fait de l'authenticité l'une des valeurs
cardinales de notre société même pour
nos hommes politiques aujourd'hui il
faut de l'authenticité ça passe par
parler vulgairement montrer qui on est
ce qu'on aime du fromage
jambon des choses très concrètes
nous avons la thèse que défend le
philosophe Gilles lipowski dans son
essai Le Sacre de l'authenticité dans
lequel il développe que la valeur
cardinale de nos sociétés est devenue de
défendre le droit d'être soi-même et on
comprend en quoi cette revendication
d'authenticité entre en contradiction
avec la lourdeur institutionnelle du
protocole monarchique davantage hérité
des sociétés holistes ou l'individu doit
s'effacer devant la structure finalement
dans son retour en arrière monarchique
la fantaisie nous propose donc aussi un
modèle anti libéral où le roi non
violent qui accepte le pouvoir par
obligation accepte finalement de
renoncer à un épanouissement lucratif et
personnel cette fameuse vie simple et
authentique à laquelle aspire nos
héritiers contemporains pour s'atteler à
une tâche qui le dépasse vise le bien
commun je vous laisse méditer là-dessus
et si ça nous montre une chose c'est que
tous ces trolls qui ont hurlé au
scandale face à la nouvelle série
d'Amazon prime non rien compris à la
fantaisie alors attention je parle pas
des critiques constructives sur le
rythme ou le scénario mais bien de ces
butors qui ont accusé la série d'être
walk pour inclure des personnages noirs
leur argument repose sur le fait que
l'univers de Tolkien se base sur
l'Europe médiévale et que par conséquent
elle doit nécessairement être blanche
alors déjà pensé qu'il y avait pas de
noir à l'époque c'est plutôt un signe
d'ignorance mais j'ai un autre scoop
pour eux le Seigneur des Anneaux a
toujours été walk le médiévalisme de
Tolkien n'est qu'un décor sur lequel il
a placé des valeurs contemporaines bien
éloignées des réalités historiques donc
si les fans peuvent se contenter d'un
roi providentiel qui gouverne avec
douceur et justesse après avoir refusé
le pouvoir presque toute sa vie il
devrait réussir à accepter des elfes ou
des nains à la peau noire
cet épisode de sociologie qui est
maintenant terminé j'espère qu'il vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce
vers le haut à partager le contenu si
vous a plu c'est une vidéo qui m'a pris
pas mal de temps donc n'hésitez pas à
partager en parler autour de vous si
vous voulez continuer à creuser le sens
sociologique du Seigneur des Anneaux et
bien sachez que j'y consacre un chapitre
entier dans mon livre Comprendre le
monde avec la pop culture donc n'hésitez
pas à aller regarder de ce côté là il y
a certains arguments que j'ai repris
dans la vidéo mais je vais beaucoup plus
loin dans le chapitre du point de vue
sociologique donc foncez n'hésitez pas
offrez-le à vos amis si la vidéo vous a
plu vous devriez pas être déçu en
attendant moi je vous fais de gros
bisous et je vous dis à la prochaine
Ciao
[Musique]